[Music]
legend has it there is a tree in the
Amazon that possesses unparalleled
healing powers and the Arrowhead is the
key to unlocking it stop on hello I just
wanted you to know this has been
mislabeled
[Music]
he's shipping outlets
of all the jungle cruisers you can take
in the Amazon
this one is undoubtedly the cheapest but
also the most thrilling heads up come a
Duke
look out
Marauders
natives ladies and gentlemen the moment
you've all been waiting for
the backside of water stays wonder of
the world
we're headed upriver lagrimas de cristal
mr. Huron travel come on not a good time
my brother looking for passage upriver
please go away
I have a lot of money have you believe
in legends do you believe in curses too
you're gonna beg me to turn back well I
look forward to disappointing you
10,000 to bring you there alive dead is
15,000 why should I pay me dead
dad I'd have to carry you dad's a lot
harder lady there we go
oh sorry Frank sorry strong form
hi Janice when you put the river cruise
and you can't swim the price just went
out
miss Israel
you